so for some of my listeners that won't
know about you right so you grew up in
California yeah yeah and
um what was y'all's neighborhood like
growing up
oh man oh
I grew up like in multiple different you
know I'm saying places
um
but it was a um
it was like
shootouts
[__] going on like that
um
was chilling in the other
and then you know I'm saying it was
robberies going on a lot heavy in one
spot
I hate robberies
we was doing them though so it was
different
yeah I guess if you yeah if you on the
receiving end of it you was different
though like a little bit different yeah
in these uh
in these apartments
was it fun or not was it scary or was it
fun no it was all fun it was yeah that'd
be the crazy thing bro like
a lot of people there grow up you know
what I'm saying living like you send me
the ghetto dangerous life
like a lot of us think it's fun
yeah I'm saying and then when you make
it out
and then you start looking back like
damn I was playing with fire like the
whole time like you'd be crazy yeah
that's what seems interesting sometimes
it's like uh it seems like this the
it seems like Grand Theft Auto sometimes
yeah you know but we never whenever you
get out of that space and you get into
like a like a I guess probably they
probably look at it as like a fancier
way of living or you make it out right
dude
do those people look differently at you
then is that kind of
um I mean it depends on
your story you know what I'm saying how
you came up and made it out and um
like you know you always gonna have a
group of people that's speaking like
down on you you know what I'm saying
negative comments but
um like when you did it like
you know I'm saying like the right way
or like you know I'm saying you kept it
solid you see me you don't have a lot of
people just like championing your name
you know yeah
um oh yeah that's I can see that dude
like like my story like you know I'm
saying if you from L.A
like if you from Los Angeles County you
know what I'm saying you know YG story
you know what I'm saying and uh you can
use like you probably damn near feel
like you know IG you know
um
so I feel like me making it out
still being out here you know what I'm
saying having success and still doing it
I feel like like a lot of people like
you know I'm saying they um support
they look up to it they support it they
can relate yeah for sure you understand
they've seen a whole come up right
you know I'm saying I was like in the
streets and [__] and I had like a
movement going on at a young age
and I had like a gang of [__]
and we was off from the same click
it was like some young High School
it was like High School
fresh out of high school ghetto ass the
kid [__] you know what I'm saying and um
you know that Movement Like helped me
like navigate through the city like like
everybody was talking about like why is
Jesus
and uh yeah
did y'all have any weaponry
hell yeah yeah
bro like like I came up
like in the club
like outside
at a young age doing all the outside
[__] you see me we was doing all the
street [__] yeah but then we was
partying we like it was the party it was
the party crew but then at the party you
know what I'm saying like I used to go
to all the parties and like you know I
used to be like
like gangbang you know at the parties in
the parties you know I'm saying we'll
have a whole bunch of like [__]
from the other side [__] and so they're
they're back they and those are the guys
you got to get those guys no it's just
we'll start getting into it in the party
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm
banging my [__] they banging they [__]
we like so what uh uh and then it'll
just started going up it'll be fights
it'll be shootouts all that type of [__]
and you um you figured out what's
happening like every other weekend [__]
yeah dang that's like a what like a
that's like the wild west man yeah well
you know what I'm saying when you like
bro when you come in L.A and you young
and [__] that's bro that [__] is regular
damn yeah
and how do you get into a gang do you
have to like apply or anything or how do
you do you gotta I mean you got to get
jumped on you know I'm saying you gotta
that's you applying I guess you got to
get what you got to get jumped on by
like multiple [__] you know and
what do you even wear to something like
that
me I had on then what I had them
when I got put on I had like a long ass
white T-shirt and some skinny jeans oh
yeah
uh not skinnied over at the time you see
me they would have called him skinny at
that time but yeah
and do you are you allowed to defend
yourself during that or no that's not
part of it hell yeah you better damn
I don't know if I could do it bro no you
can't fight I can yeah so you good I
don't know though I can't fight that
good oh I can't you can't yeah do you
miss it sometimes what fun yeah I mean
just because now your life is a little
different you know you don't have to
fight as much I mean you don't have to
battle every day
you know what I'm saying
now it's like [__] don't fight
no more you know I know yeah it's
changed a lot huh it's changed a lot
yeah people trying to follow people huh
people unfollow people oh yeah that's
their thing you know it's like it's
definitely a lot different
do you look at the younger generation be
like damn these cats got it easy
or do you think they just haven't done
no no I just think it's different
because
like
when I was a young [__] the
[__] older than us
like
we hate to hear like all the
[__] got it easy like nah like
you sound like a hater
you know what I'm saying it's just
different like time's changing you know
yeah
and what other Weaponry would y'all use
only guns or any would people have some
like uh
bats or
Knuckles bows no that's NWA type [__]
yeah it wasn't like that you know we
wouldn't have no fashion [__] you know
what I'm saying what
um what's the best type of weapon for a
hold up do you think
for who for like a hold up you're gonna
hold somebody up you're gonna stick
somebody up for rob somebody yeah rob
somebody if you're going to rob somebody
what's the best
what do you think
oh a pistol yeah
[__] scared of that oh yeah oh
if I see a pistol I get scared sometimes
my arms won't move
like I lock up you know damn
when you left when you moved out of
there did you have to like have a formal
meeting with everybody like hey guys I
just want you to know no like
bro I was living like like I was living
in Inglewood
for for many like
but I was like when I started like
having success like I was living in
Inglewood
like there's smack in the middle for the
ghetto and everybody knew where I lived
at
like yeah you know what I'm saying and
um you know I'm saying I was having like
songs on the radio doing all type of
leaving out of town going on tour
while Mom and him at the house
you know what I'm saying
um
well yeah when I got up out of here
like I just got on
I went to the valley
damn I went to the valley but I left the
valley because I'm like this [__] weak
the valley was hell yeah yeah it's a lot
of ubereats and [__] out there no this
is like you feel me this like
2013. oh yeah you know what I'm saying
[Laughter]
Huntington Beach or something damn yeah
bro I was all over the place like my
whole life out here I've been all over
the place like
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one